yeah I think where it has has mostly
been in the opportunity with booked a
bond with people in the industry
certainly wouldn't in the Bay Area where
I've most started most of my businesses
it's really a non-issue and in fact it
can even be a plus because there's so
much networking within the gay world
there but like there was an instance
where a couple you know a guy who was
very senior at Facebook and and has
moved on to an even bigger role
elsewhere as a guy a really good guy to
know very smart guy I've known him for
10 years and you know he and another guy
I know and and went on kind of a stag
trip to Las Vegas and and I didn't I
wasn't invited and didn't know about it
and found out afterwards and it was fine
but you know I I think they wouldn't
have felt comfortable with me being
there because it was kind of a stag male
bonding thing and and I probably would
have been comfortable in it the other
thing that happens is increasingly I've
chosen not to have kids I realize you
can't have kids as a gay adult but I've
chosen not to and increasingly people's
live center around their families and
social calendars so there's I think
there's just stuff that maybe I'm not as
connected with people because I don't
set up playdates with their kids and my
kids and all that kind of stuff so
there's some social aspects maybe that I
miss out on but there's never been any
sort of problem with anyone finding out
that I was gay and suddenly not wanting
to do business with me or not wanting to
fund me or you know in fact typically
what happens because I was afraid to
tell people but when I finally told
people at at wine shopper the management
team it was amazing it really was
amazing and I was in a fraternity in
college and you know I've learned how to
sort of fit in to a very male-dominated
dominated environment and was just fine
at it so I tend to just slip into that
but you know what I don't do anymore
is I don't feign interest in sports
because I'm simply not and I don't feign
interest in girls because I'm simply not
and so whereas up until maybe even ten
years ago I would sort of you know jump
in on those conversations and it just
felt so wrong right so I think that was
that's the only issues is is maybe just
missing out on some bonding
opportunities with people that are
straight oriented like family stuff and
stuff but other than that not really
initiative
you know I thought I looked at that
question and you know I my favorite
business icon is as Steve Jobs in terms
of my role model and he's not gay but I
couldn't I couldn't think of anyone in
the business world that I knew was gay
and that I think is telling right
because I'm sure that some of these very
successful business people that are out
there are gay but they're not out and so
that's why it's difficult to answer that
question and in the business world
because you know I know confidentially
so I won't say but I can think of five
major household name companies where I
know either the CEO or very senior
people who are gay and but they're very
careful about it and so hey you know I
think the business world is kind of the
last frontier I think for that kind of
diversity to really take hold and it's
it's a I don't know it's it's
interesting it also is very regional I
think if you're in it's big difference
if you're trying to do business in
perhaps a more conservative part of the
country then it would be if you're doing
business in San Francisco in New York
we're really it is completely a
non-issue
it's just irrelevant
yeah there are issues I mean certainly I
think in the in the Arab world for
example I think it would be very
challenging and China I don't know as
much about their views on homosexuality
but imagine not great you know the
bottom line is that business unless
you're in the sex business there is no
reason to mix sex and business and just
like in the straight world it would be
inappropriate in a meeting to discuss
your fetishes or something like that and
and you know your wife you know you just
don't talk about it and so it it really
doesn't need to be relevant and it
doesn't need to be discussed and it
would be weird
I actually I've always been of the
belief that I should just be myself and
if someone asks me are you gay oh I will
answer them honestly but I'm not going
to broadcast it necessarily because it's
a it's it's a personal characteristic of
me
I was made this way and it's nothing
that everybody I need to rub in
everybody's face I mean it's just a it's
an it's an aspect of me I have no
problems with it I'm proud of myself but
it isn't something I need to wear on my
sleeve and so I just can't think of you
know in 20 years of doing business in
some form I can't think of any situation
where it's ever come up in any kind of
meeting with you know become as Sony
Dell staples all sorts of big
corporations I've met with New York
Times you know and it just never comes
up which is great
you